Hello, this is Dr. Savinova
speaking. Today I'm recording
a lecture on the physiology
of thermoregulation.
During this lecture, I
will compare and contrast
skin temperature and
core body temperature at
different conditions, describe
a homeostatic mechanism
maintaining a stable
core body temperature,
including heat production
and heat dissipation. We
will understand the mechanism
by which the central
nervous system regulates
body temperature and
will describe the mechanisms
controlling fever.
Internal body temperature
is maintained within a
narrow range, which is
optimized for the biological
reactions to proceed.
Both extreme cold and heat
temperature can lead to
protein denaturation and
tissue damage, which is
incompatible with life.
For the discussion of
temperature regulation, we will
distinguish between the
core body temperature, which
represents the temperature
of the internal organs
in the brain, and the skin
temperature, also known as
shell temperature. The core
temperature remains stable
over the wide range of
external conditions, whereas
the skin temperature
can increase or decrease
depending on the surrounding
environmental temperatures.
what is the normal body
temperature a temperature of
98.6 or 37 degree Celsius
was considered normal for
a long time interestingly
this temperature of 98
.6 stem from a data published
in in 18 in In 1868 by
the German physician Karl
Wunderlich, who invented
the clinical thermometer.
He was also the first to
realize that fever is a
symptom, not a disease. He took
over 1 million temperature
measurements from 25
,000 patients, which is
astonishing number for those
days of research. He reported
a range of temperature
in this group, noting that
men and older people had
lower temperature than
women and young adults, and
that the temperature was
higher in the afternoon than
in the morning hours.
However, the overall number
of 98.6, which was an
average temperature in this
population, stuck in a
physician's consciousness for
a century and a half. A
recent study, however, has
found that the average body
temperature in the U.S.
has dropped from 98.6
by about 0.05 degree
Fahrenheit of each decade
since the 19th century.
Today's normal body
temperature in healthy
adults is about 97.9
with a range of 97.8 to
98.2 degree Fahrenheit
when measured ******.
The body temperature varies
throughout the day. It
can change up to 0.9 to 1
.8 degrees Fahrenheit from
early morning to late
afternoon, with the minimum
temperature typically occurring
between 3 and 5 in the
morning and the maximum
temperature between 4 and 6 p.m.
The clinical ramification
is that you must apply
different criteria for defining
the fever in the morning
versus the afternoon. In
the morning 98.9 degree
Fahrenheit is considered the
fever whereas in afternoon
and overall threshold for
the fever in adults is 99.9
degree Fahrenheit. This was
recognized even in 1992,
more than 30 years ago,
and published in the
Journal of the American
Medical Association.
Another recent study from
Stanford University also
advocates for the personalized
approach to temperature
measurements. A survey
of more than 100,000
patients aged 20 to 80 demonstrated
that men systematically
had lower temperature
than women. temperature
decreased with age in
both men and women in an
increase in weight was
associated with higher oral
temperature in both sexes on
the other hand the increase
in height was associated
with decreased in oral
temperature in both sexes
thus you can imagine the
scenario when they're Tall
older gentleman at 80 years
of age, let's say, in the
morning has almost would
have almost one degree
lower temperature than the
younger young woman in
her 20s who is overweight
and taking the temperature
in the afternoon. So the
difference between individuals
could be quite high.
it is essential to consider
the patient profile and
the time of the day the
temperature is measurement this
group of researchers from
Stanford University also
developed a tool a clinical
tool to estimate normal
temperature ranges in which
you can plug the patient ***
height, weight, and exact time
of the day the temperature
is taken to determine
the normal range for this
particular situation in
this particular person. And
the temperature that would
exceed 99 percentile could
be considered in elevated
temperature in this patient.
As you might anticipate,
the normal temperature range in
children is higher
than in adults.
In the pediatric population,
babies younger than three
months of age had significantly
higher temperature
than other children in one
study. pediatric fever is
also high has a high
threshold of 104 point four
degrees Fahrenheit compared
to 99.9 in adults a fever is
a body normal response to
infection or tissue damage
our children of different ages
have different sensitivity
and tolerance to elevated
temperature therefore
you have different
recommendations for when to see
doctor for the pediatric
population in the different
brackets particularly
stringent recommendation is for
newborn and the babies
younger than three months of
age so now that we have
considered normal temperature
from the clinical perspective
we will talk about
physiology the amount of
heat stored within the body
reflects the balance between
heat production and the
amount of heat transferred
from the external environment
to the external environment
human regulate body
temperature within a
narrow range despite large
fluctuations of the ambient
temperature surrounding them it
is achieved by balancing
the flow of heat energy
from the internal organs of
the body to the environment
some energy generalized
through the general generated
through the metabolic
processes is concerned
converted into mechanical
work against gravity but most
energy is exchanged with
the environment through heat
transfer heat is in
change it is exchanged by
convection radiation and latent
heat transfer through the
evaporation by definition
convection is a heat transfer
through direct contact
convection is heat transfer
through the movement of
air or water radiation is
a transfer of heat through
electromagnetic waves
without any direct contact
and evaporation requires
energy to transfer between
the to make the phase transfer
of water between the liquid
phase and vapor state
heat is constantly produced
in the body as a byproduct
of metabolism necessary
to maintain all chemical
reactions in the brain and
internal organs we are not
talking about exercise yet
we define the basic metabolic
rate or the resting
metabolic rate as a metabolic
rate under standard conditions
at rest the standard
conditions are defined as
12 hour hours of fast in
the morning after 30 minutes
at a quiet rest under a
comfortable temperature of
about 77 degree fahrenheit
more than 70 percent
of heat in the body at
rest is produced by
the visceral organs and
the brain Although
collectively these organs
constitute only about
36% of body mass,
remarkably the brain, which
accounts for only 2% of
body mass, produces 16%
of heat at rest. the basic
resting metabolic rate can
be measured by direct or
indirect colorimetry or can
be estimated based on the
person's age height and weight
and *** the metabolic rate
varies approximately in
proportion to the body surface
area among subject of
different body sizes the
ratio of metabolic rate to
body surface area is highest
in infancy and declines
with age most rapidly in
childhood and adolescence
and then slower thereafter
children have the highest
metabolic rate because of the
energy necessary to sustain
growth similarly a woman's
metabolic rate increases
during pregnancy to supply
energy needed for to support
the development of the
features however non-pregnant
women's metabolic rate
is about five to ten percent
lower than that of men at
of the same age in surface
area probably because of
the typically high proportion
of adipose tissue in a
female's body composition
other factors affecting
metabolic rate are hormones
and the fasted or fat state
catecholamines and tyroxine
are the hormones that have
the greatest effect on the
metabolic metabolic rate
catecholamines cause
glycogen to break down into
glucose and stimulate many
enzyme systems increasing
cellular metabolism hypermetabolism
is a clinical feature
of theochromocytoma a
catecholamine producing tumor
of the adrenal medulla it
might be associated with
this condition may be
associated with weight loss and
heat intolerance taroxin
magnifies the metabolic
responses of catecholamines
increasing protein synthesis
and stimulating fuel uh
fat oxidation by in the
mitochondria the metabolic
rate is in uh is typically
about 45 above normal in
persons with hyperthyroidism
and could be 25% below
normal in persons affected by
hypothyroidism. These
conditions can lead to weight
loss and heat intolerance
in hyper or with gain and
cold intolerance in
hyperthyroidism. After ovulation,
progesterone produces
by the corpus Lithium is
the primary hormone
responsible for the transient
elevation of body
temperature after ovulation.
Digestion is another
significant factor,
elevating body temperature.
Digestion may account
for the up to 10 to 20%
increase in the metabolic
rate after a meal.
Digestion of fats and
proteins is more effective
in increasing body
temperature than digesting
carbohydrate because
it takes more energy to
break down fats and
proteins compared to sugars.
Most energy produced
after meal comes from
the liver, which is a
major metabolic organ.
During exercise,
the skeletal muscle becomes
the principal source of
metabolic heat and may
account for up to 90% of heat
produced in the body.
Moderate intense exercise by
healthy but sedentary young
men may require a metabolic
rate increase of 6 to 8
fold compared to rest.
Intense activity by
a trained athlete may
require a 10 fold
or more increase in
metabolic rate to
sustain that activity.
Because of the high metabolic
rate, exercising muscle
may be 1 to 2 degree warmer
than the core temperature.
The blood perfusing the
warm muscles is returning
to the core, increases
the core body temperature.
The integumentary system,
particularly the skin, is
important in thermoregulation.
The heat produced in the
core is transferred to the
skin, where it is lost to air
and other surrounding.
Therefore, the rate at which
heat is lost is determined
entirely by two factors. How
rapidly heat can be conducted
from where it is produced
in a core to the skin, and
how rapidly heat can be
transferred from the skin
surface to the surroundings.
Then the subcutaneous tissue,
especially the subcutaneous
fat, acts together as
a heat insulator of the
body. The insulating
properties of the skin and
subcutaneous tissue are such
that are sufficient to maintain
stable core temperature
at ambient temperature
without even any additional
heat produced in a body.
All right, so because the
skin's nutritional needs of
the skin is low, the blood
flow to the skin surface
is controlled primarily by
the reflexes in response
to changes in the temperature.
In most skin surfaces,
the vasodilation during
heat exposure depends
on the sympathetic
neural signal that causes
the blood vessels to
dilate. Because it depends
on the action of the
neuronal stimulation,
such vasodilation is
called active vasodilation.
Active vasodilation
occurs everywhere except
the hands, feet, lips,
ears and nose. Human skin
innervation is unique
in that two distinct
branches of sympathetic
neural system, the adrenergic
vasoconstrictor and
cholinergic vasodilator,
regulate cutaneous blood flow.
the adrenergic the adrenergic
vasoconstrictor system
behaves in the skin in
the same way as most other
vascular beds such as in a
skeletal muscle and other
systems norepinephrine is
released from sympathetic
nerve terminal binds to
alpha receptor and induces
vasoconstriction. The adrenergic
vasoconstrictor system
becomes more effective in
response to the reduction
in skin temperature. During
heat stress, the initial
increase in skin blood
flow is achieved simply by
the withdrawal of tonic
adrenergic vasoconstriction
however if the core temperature
continue to rise and
more blood needs to be
redirected to the skin the
cholinergic signaling is
activated and induces active
vasodilation through the
binding tool of acetylcholine
uh to the muscarinic
receptors on vascular
smooth muscle cells of
cutaneous blood vessels
which further increases
the which increases the
synthesis of nitric oxide
important was a dilator in
further increases the blood
flow human thermoregulation
also depends on
sweat evaporation
from the skin surfaces.
Body temperature
increases significantly in
person with reduced
ability to sweat or in
person wearing clothing,
which is wet or does
not allow moisture to
escape very easily.
Sweat is produced by
acrine sweat glands
distributed throughout
the entire body
surface. The density
of these glands is most
uniform throughout,
is most uniform, I'm
sorry, the density of the
sweat glands are the densest
in palms and soles. Sweat
glands are the tubular
structures consisting of
two parts, a deep subdermal
sweat-producing portion
that secretes the sweat,
and the dermal portion, the
duct portion that passes
from the dermis and
epidermis layer of the skin.
Like any other glands,
the secretory portion of
a sweat gland secretes a
fluid called the primary
secretion or the
precursor secretion. The
concentration of
constitutive in a precursor
secretion is modified as
it flows through the duct.
The composition of the
precursor secretion is similar
to that of plasma, except
it doesn't contain plasma
proteins. As the precursor
solution flows through
the ducts, most of the
sodium and chloride are
reabsorbed. The degree of
this reabsorption depends on
the rate of sweating.
When the sweat glands are
stimulated only slightly,
the precursor fluid flows
through the duct slowly.
The sodium and chloride ions
are almost completely
reabsorbed under the slow
flow, reducing the osmotic
pressure of the sweat fluid
to such a low level that
most of water is also
leaving the duct and get
reabsorbed through the duct.
cells.
So as a result, the
sweat gland produces a
very concentrated
sweat fluid devoted of
sodium and chloride,
but enriched in urea,
lactic acid, and
potassium ions. Thus,
sweating is also an
additional mean of
excreting urea and
lactic acid in the body.
Conversely, when the
sympathetic nervous
system is strongly
stimulated and
sweat is produced
at a very high rate,
the large amount of precursor
secretion is formed,
and under high flow, the
duct may reabsorb less
than half of the secreted
sodium chloride, resulting
in a high amount of sodium
and chloride excretion.
Furthermore,
sweat flows through
the gland so rapidly
that little water is
also reabsorbed. A
significant amount of
electrolytes can be
lost if the person is
unaccustomed to heat.
the process during the
process of heat acclimation
two things happen first
a person will sweat more
and the concentration of
sodium chloride sodium
chloride sodium and
chloride ions in sweat will
become reduced conserving
electrolyte when a person
accustomed to heat to
is exposed to a hot
environment they will produce
they can produce up to
three liters of sweat per
hour compared to about one
liter per hour in a person
unaccustomed to heat
evaporation of a large
amount of sweat from the skin
surface after clean skin
after heat acclimation
can efficiently remove heat
from the body at a rate
more than 10 times of the
normal basal metabolic rate
and associated further
progressively better
conservation of electrolyte in
the body most of this effect
is most of the most of
the acclimation effect to
the heat is facilitated by
the excess production of
of aldosterone by the
adrenal gland which helps
sodium reabsorption in the
sweat gland by increasing
the expression of the
epithelial sodium channel
on the luminal
surface of the duct,
which is responsible for
the sodium reabsorption.
A person unaccustomed
to heat often
loses 15 to 30 grams
of salt each day for
the first few days
of heat exposure.
After four to six weeks,
the same person would only
lose about 3 to 5 grams of
sodium chloride per day.
Temperature sensing neuron
and neuronal endings are
present in both the
periphery and in the central
nervous system. The integration
of the signal within
the CNS thermoregulatory
network permits a rapid
and effective balance of
heat loss and heat production
that maintains a normal
core body temperature.
Specialized peripheral
sensory neurons, also known as
thermoreceptor, provides
the CNS with information
about the thermal condition of
the skin. The thermosensitive
element of the thermal
receptor are the free
nerve endings that are
distributed over the entire
skin surface and contain
cation channels that alter
their conductance as the
environmental temperature rises.
Peripheral thermoreceptors
fall into two categories,
warmth receptor and cold
receptor. Each type is
anatomically distinct, and
each innervates definable
warmth and cold sensitive
spots on the skin surface.
thermal discrimination varies
over the body surface it
is the coarsest on the trunk
and limbs and finest on
the face lips and fingertips
a warm receptor increase
the steady firing rate at
the local temp as the local
temperature increases cold
receptors which are the
predominant skin thermal
receptors characteristically
increase the steady firing
rate as the local skin
temperature decreases because
of the allocation skin thermal
receptors primarily
provides the hypothalamic
regulatory centers with information
about ambient temperature
skin thermal receptors
provide an anticipatory feed
forward signal relying
information to on the changes
in ambient temperature to the
central thermal regulatory
network which drives reflex
thermal regulation and
thereby minimizes changes
in the core temperature the
information information from
the skin thermal receptors
also travels from the
thalamic pathways to the
cerebral cortex, thus providing
the basis for conscious
perception of thermal
environment. That way we can
localize the thermal stimuli
to the particular surface of
the exposed skin and have
an appreciation of the
thermal comfort. The thalamic
cortical pathways may be
responsible for triggering
behavioral thermoregulation.
The principal mechanism
through which the central
thermal regulatory network
senses changes in a in a in the
in the body temperature in
the core body temperature
is through the warmth sensing
neurons located in the
pre-optical optic area of
the anterior hypothalamus
as the skin thermal receptors
As in the skin thermal
receptors, these neurons
express cation conductance
channels with the ability to
change the discharge rate as
the temperature of the
local environment increases.
Sensing core body temperature
by pre-optic thermosensitive
neurons is essentially
important during exercise
intake of hot fluids or the
resolution of the fever.
when it prompts an increase
in heat loss and avoids
significant changes in
the core body temperature.
Thermo-effector mechanisms
include behavioral changes,
cutaneous vasodilation,
sweating,
and skeletal muscle responses.
Humans have become quite
adept in devising behavioral
adaptations that permit
survival in a wide range
of environmental temperatures
as temperature changes
the behavior from simply
moving out of the hot
Sun into the shade or
building a fire or turning on
the air conditioner he is
a has became a habitual
to us to the degree that
we don't even realize that
this is the thermoregulatory
repertoire behavior
is also an essential
anticipatory mechanism
for example we are
accustomed to put on the
extra clothing like a
jacket when going outside
in anticipation of
the cold environment.
The thermal effectors that
moderate heat transfer
to the environment are
under the control of
sympathetic nervous system,
adjusting the smooth muscle
tone of cutaneous arterioles
and arterial venous
anastomosis. Active
vasodilation can increase
cutaneous flow up to tenfold
above the resting level
when it is necessary to
increase heat dissipation
conversely when it's
necessary to conserve heat in
cold environment cutaneous
cutaneous blood flow
falls partially by the
inhibiting active vasodilation
and increasing sympathetic
mediated cutaneous
vasoconstriction. As
vasoconstriction increases,
the reduced flow of warm
blood to the cutaneous
circulation causes skin
temperature to fall
even closer to ambient
temperature, further
activating the cold thermal
receptors and reinforcing
the response in the
feed-forward mechanism.
When the heat load
is high and the
core body temperature
increases,
the preoptic warmth
-sensitive neuron activates
sweating, which elevates
the partial pressure
of water vapor on skin
surface and promotes
evaporation, taking the
heat away from the skin.
The innervation of the
secretory segment of
sweat glands is sympathetic,
but it is unusual
in that the cholinergic
signaling is involved
with acetylcholine
and neurotransmitter.
Before sweating can lead
to the loss of large amount
of water and electrolyte,
adequate degradation in
hot environment is essential
to prevent circulatory
collapse and fatal
hyperthermia. As cold stress
increases, cutaneous
vasoconstriction is supplemented
with heat production by
thermogenesis. Initially,
thermogenesis in brown adipose
tissue and subsequently
thermogenesis in the
muscle through shivering.
brown adipose tissue is
the heat producing adipose
tissue both in humans and
animals in infants brown
adipose tissue is located
in the interscapular space
similar to small mammals
but it regresses with age
and almost completely lost
in adulthood the typical
subclavicular and and
paravertebral brown adipose
tissue distribution seen
in adult humans appears to
develop closer to puberty in
boys and girls. Brown adipose
tissue cells differ from
white adipose adipocytes
in that they contain
numerous small lipid vacuoles
and many well-developed
mitochondria. In contrast,
white adipocytes are
characterized by a single,
large lipid vocal and fewer
mitochondria. The hallmark
of brown adipose tissue
at the molecular level in
animals and humans is the
high level of expression
of uncoupling protein 1,
or UCP1. UCP-1 is found
in the inner mitochondrial
membrane, where it uncouples
mitochondrial respiration
from ATP synthesis.
When activated,
UCP-1 causes a leak that
dissipates electrochemical
proton gradient that
builds across the inner
mitochondrial membrane
during fatty acid
oxidation. This electrochemical
proton gradient drives
the conversion of ADP
to ATP by ATP synthase,
the main ATP-producing
mechanism in the body.
when ucp1 abolish uncouples
the mitochondria it's
also abolishes the negative
feedback inhibition
exerted by the etp on a
krebs cycle and respiration
and that leads to a
very high of fatty acid
oxidation that directly
produces heat brown adipose
tissue is essentially the
only tissue in the body
that can literally burn
fats the sympathetic nervous
system heavily innervates
brown adipocytes
releasing norepinephrine
that activates thermogenesis
color called the
temperature picked up by the
pre-optic neurons also
increase the production of
tyrotropin releasing
hormone in the hypothalamus
and consequently
increases the circulating
levels of thyroid hormones
thyroid hormones further
increase the expression
of ucp1 protein in brown
adipocyte and further
stimulate thermogenesis
when the brown adipose
tissue thermogenesis is
insufficient to control stable
core temperature shivering
begins with an often
unrecognized increase in
basal skeletal muscle tone
followed by an involuntary
clonic rhythmic contraction
and relaxation of
skeletal muscles Shivering
can triple or even quadruple
the metabolic rate for
brief intervals or double
the metabolic rate for quite
extended period of time
before fatigue occurs. The
same motor neurons that
innervate skeletal muscle
for normal body movement
and posture also drive
shivering. Normally, the
somatic motor system
establishes and coordinates
voluntary movement and is
not controlled by central
mechanisms independent of
those controlling by the
mechanism, by the sympathetic
nervous system. However,
under the cold environment,
the sympathetic nervous
system can take over
the motor control and
motor neurons and induce
shivering thermogenesis.
Under those conditions,
the voluntary
movement, such as
producing speech or other
fine motor skills,
can be hampered. The
engagement of specific
thermoregulatory
mechanism is
hierarchical, meaning that
different effectors
become activated at
different temperature
thresholds. In general,
behavioral responses are
utilized in preference to
autonomic effectors, and
autonomic effectors are
activated in a specific
sequence. The sequence is
thought to reflect the cost
of activating different
responses in terms of energy
used or the trade-offs
they require with competing
physiologic system.
For example,
heat challenges
trigger vasodilation at
lower temperature followed
by sweating, possibly
because sweating
results in water loss
and can upset the fluid
balance. Similarly,
cold challenges activate
vasoconstriction
before shivering or
brown adipose tissue
thermogenesis in accordance
with the relative
energy cost of this
different mechanism.
The existence of this
distinct temperature threshold
has been interpreted
as evidence that
thermoregulatory circuit
contains multiple loops, each
of which operates to some
extent independently.
The human core body temperature
is about 98.8 degree
plus minus a fraction of
the degree. This crucial
temperature level is
controlled by the hypothalamic
temperature set point,
which serves as a body
internal thermostat. The
temperature control mechanisms
are all designed to continue
attempt to bring the
core body temperature back
to the set point level.
The primary autonomic
defenses against heat are
shivering and active
cutaneous vasodilation.
Meanwhile, the primary
autonomic defenses against the
cold are vasoconstriction
and active thermogenesis.
Body temperature is typically
maintained between the
sweating threshold and weather
constriction threshold.
Temperature that defines
inter-threshold range
are also called a null
zone. The onset of
sweating usually defines
the upper boundary of the
null zone and the normal
body temperature, and
the cutaneous weather
constriction defines
the lower temperature of
the normal body range.
So now lastly on the
mechanism of fever.
Fever is ultimately
related to the hypothalamus
set point. Here what
happens. Bacterial
viruses and other infectious
agents or tissue damage
following ischemia,
inflammation, or necrosis
activate innate immune
cells to produce
pyrogenic cytokines,
including IL-1, IL-2, IL-6,
TNF-alpha, interferon
-gamma. Bacterial product can
also travel through the
bloodstream to the hypothalamus
and directly act on the
warmth-sensitive neurons.
Bacterial product of
pyrogenic cytokine
induces the synthesis
of prostaglandin
E2, PGE2, in the hypothalamus.
PGE2 acts on the warmth
-sensitive neurons of the
hypothalamus and raises the
internal temperature set point
to a higher level. Now the
body perceives that the
core temperature is below
the temperature set point, so
it will activate the
mechanism to increase the
temperature, including
thermogenesis and heat conservation.
During the resolution
of the fever,
when the infalting
stimuli are removed,
bacteria is cleared, the
tissue is healed, the
temperature set point
will suddenly drop to
its normal level. This
is called a crisis.
During the crisis, again,
in the hypothalamus,
temperature-sensitive neurons
will perceive that the
body is overheated, which
it is under those
conditions, and activate heat
dissipating mechanism,
including cutaneous vasodilation
and sweating. Although
fever is a normal
response to infection and
tissue damage, you can
interfere with the fever
cascade at several points.
Corticosteroids
will inhibit the
production of
pyrogenic cytokine.
Non-steroidal anti
-inflammatory drugs,
NSAIDs, inhibit the
synthesis of prostaglandin
E2 by inhibiting
COX oxygenases.
Lastly, you can interfere
with shivering by
administering dantrolene, which
interferes with excitation
-contraction coupling
in the skeletal muscle.
in summary thermoregulatory
mechanisms maintain the
core body temperature
stable the skin temperature
can fluctuate with the
environment heat dissipates
by the thermal radiation
evaporation of sweat and
heat conduction to the ground
or air cutaneous Massive
vasodilation increases
heat transfer from the
core of the body surface
and helps heat dissipation.
The major sources of
heat in the body are
metabolism and normal
physical activity.
Additional heat can be
produced from food digestion
and thermogenesis. The
thermoregulatory center in the
hypothalamus responds to
changes in skin and core
temperature to activate or
suppress neuronal and endocrine
regulation of thermogenesis
and heat dissipation.
Fever is defined as an
increase in hypothalamic
temperature set point, which
results in activation of
heat production and reduction
of heat dissipation.
Thank you for listening.
Please submit your
feedback by going to
the link in this slide.